aquí tenemos la gráfica de la curva de
igual a cruce no de equis y lo que
queremos hacer es determinar el área
entre la curva igual a kossen de x de la
curva blanca y el eje x para varios
intervalos vamos a empezar con este de
acá que va de 0 a medios entonces
queremos determinar esta área que estoy
sombreando en azul va cómo le hacemos
pues tenemos ya un simbolito que lo
denota la integral de 0 a medios y
medios de coseno jose no de x de x
recuerda que esto lo que nos quiere
decir es que estamos haciendo una suma
de una infinidad de rectángulos por ahí
podemos imaginarnos los una infinidad de
rectángulos que son infinitamente flacos
y eso justo nos va a dar el área es un
límite de una aproximación de riman
bueno como le vamos a hacer para
encontrar el valor de esta integral pues
vamos a utilizar el segundo teorema
fundamental del cálculo y para eso
necesitamos encontrar una anti derivada
de coseno de x entonces una función que
derivada
de echo seno de ellos bueno pues lo que
sabemos lo que sabemos es que la
derivada con respecto a x de seno de x
de seno de x es igual a coseno de x
entonces seno de x es una de las anti
derivadas de coseno de x coseno de que
tiene más anti derivadas de hecho se
hacen de x le sumamos cualquier
constante si derivamos con respecto a x
seno de x más cualquier constante nos
sigue quedando coseno de x porque la
derivada de cualquier constante ya sea 7
o 2 mil o un millón o cualquier número
loco la derivada de cualquier constante
de cero así que esto sería coseno de x
pero vaya vas a encontrar una anti
derivada para realizar los cálculos si
quieres piensa le porque no importa qué
constante pongamos nos va a dar lo mismo
pero bueno con esto en mente
esto nos quedaría igual a igual a y aquí
hay que ponerle el seno de x
y los límites serían de 0 a y medios
cuando queda la cuenta pues nos quedaría
senodep y medios senodep y medios menos
seno de 0 seno de cero senodep y medios
es 1
voy a poner así es 1 seno de 0 es cero
entonces nos quedaría igual a 1 muy bien
entonces esta área que marque en azul
esta área es de 1 van ahí estoy marcando
el 1
bueno vamos a pasar a otro intervalo
ahora vamos a pasar al intervalo que va
de pi medios a tres y medios y lo voy a
poner por acá nada más dejan indicar la
región que nos interesa con este color
rosa entonces lo que queremos ahora es
calcular el área de esta región y para
encontrarla necesitamos calcular la
integral definida depp y medios de pi y
medios a tres primeros tres pi medios
otra vez de coseno de x coseno de x de x
muy bien ya no bueno si voy a poner esto
seno de x pero ya no voy a hacer todo
esto verdad porque ya sabemos quién es
una anti derivada entonces aquí nada más
le pongo seno de x 19 x de 0 no aquí ya
no va de 0 ver activa de pi medios y
medios a tres primeros
y cuánto nos quedaría esto nos quedaría
igual a seno de 3 y medios tres medios
menos seno de iu de medios si no
recordamos cuando éste nos de tres
medios podemos dibujar nuestro círculo
unitario para acordarnos entrada
entonces ahí están los ejes por ahí que
del círculo unitario entonces 3 y medios
es dar tres cuartos de vuelta
llegaríamos acá seno es la altura como
vamos para abajo es menos uno entonces
aquí nos quedaría menos uno menos
senodep y medios senodep y medios
primeros destaca la altura es uno
entonces es menos uno menos uno que es
igual a menos dos guau quedo negativo
entonces qué quería decir este menos dos
en el mundo real pues no tenemos áreas
negativas verdad las áreas siempre son
positivas pero vamos a intentar
interpretar esto en términos de algo
entonces déjame poner en menudos por acá
y pensemos pues ve este 2 nos indica que
en valor absoluto del área en efecto
vale 2
como normalmente la pensamos pero el
menos el menos lo que nos indica es que
el área está por debajo por debajo del
eje x entonces eso está bueno verdad el
signo nos va a indicar si queramos si
tenemos área por arriba o si tenemos
área por abajo vale entonces el 2 es el
área en valor absoluto del menos es que
está por abajo bueno vamos a hacer un
caso más vamos a integrar ahora de 0 a 3
y medios entonces el área que nos
interesa va a quedar un poco encima da
pero ahora es va a ser esta área naranja
con esta área vamos a integrar eso de
allí entonces ahora esa área naranja va
a ser la integral
la integral de 0 a 3 primeros 3 y medios
de coseno de xx coseno de x de x y eso
es igual a pues ya no hago tanto lío
nada más le voy a poner seno de tres
primeros tres primeros menos seno de
cero seno de tres y medios es menos uno
verdad entonces esto nos quedaría igual
a menos 1 - 0 o sea simplemente queda
menos uno vaya entonces ahora esta área
naranja dice que vale menos uno no está
raro verdad porque aquí hay un área de
uno en valor absoluto y aquí de dos y
hay cosas arriba y abajo entonces vamos
a intentar darle una interpretación a
este menos uno vamos a pensarlo tantito
de dónde podría venir pues ve en el área
azul nos quedaba que esto media 1 de
área y acá en el área rosa rosa mexicano
nos quedaba que era menos 2 entonces es
justo lo que está calculando este menos
1 es el área neta que queda por arriba
del eje x
el área por arriba la toma positiva el
área por abajo la toma negativa y
entonces integrar desde cero hasta tres
y medios lo que está haciendo es
considerar en total que tan arriba
estamos del eje x vale entonces que
indicaría este negativo pues este menos
1 nos diría que hay más área por abajo
que por arriba de hecho que el área por
abajo éste le ganen 1 al área por arriba
y por eso nos queda el menos 1 vale
entonces la integral de arriba nace esta
cosa chistosa que considera el área neta
para los de arriba con más lo de abajo
con menos bueno eso es si es negativo
qué pasaría si nos quedara igual a cero
que nos diría una integral igual a cero
pues para eso vamos a hacer un último
ejemplo y ahora vamos a integrar en todo
el intervalo desde 0 hasta 2 hasta 2 pi
vamos a calcular la integral de 0 a 2
p2p de coseno de x de x y entonces ahora
estamos calculando todo esto con todo
esto con todo esto si lo pensamos
tantito aquí hay un área de uno que hay
un área de 1
y hay un área de dos entonces en total
nos debería de dar 0 vamos a ver si en
efecto si da 0 entonces nos quedaría
seno de 2 pd2 pi menos seno de 0 seno de
dos pies 0 senos de 000 00 y en efecto
tenemos un área igual a cero este cero
no quiere decir que no haya área en
efecto si hay área pero el cero lo que
nos dice es que el área de arriba se
compensa por con el área de abajo